most superhero games give you all the
power you are of course the hero of the
story with marvel's guardians of the
galaxy idos montreal is taking a
different approach putting you into a
superhero team with the focus on making
you feel like part of the group you
can't handle everything on your own but
it's remarkable how through the teamwork
mechanics within the game you quickly
start to feel like you can work together
with the other guardians to stop any
obstacle we recently got a chance to
play a chapter of guardians of the
galaxy which showed off some of how
you'll interact with the other members
of the team as the story unfolds and how
you'll act as the guardian's leader on
the battlefield if you want to see more
guardians coverage from gamespot make
sure to hit the like and subscribe
buttons below
the portion we played takes place on a
nova core station called the rock where
the guardians had to pay a fine in order
to get the interstellar fuzz off their
backs it starts in typical guardians
fashion the team doesn't agree on the
best course of action gamora thinks it's
a good idea to settle up on the fine
even though it's costly so the guardians
won't have to keep looking over their
shoulders rocket on the other hand wants
to just make a run for it and keep the
cash as peter quill aka star-lord you
agree with gamora even before you take
off though you have the opportunity to
talk to the other members of the squad
that includes a quick heart to heart
with rocket to convince him that his
opinion is valued among the guardians
and a chance to learn about gamora's
secret hobby collecting dolls soon after
landing at the rock the guardians
quickly start to suspect that something
is wrong none of the space bureaucrats
are at their posts and the station
appears to be empty so there's no one to
pay the fine to the group decides to
head further into the station but to do
that you need rocket to put his
engineering skills to work to help open
some doors that highlights the guardian
request system when you need someone
else on the team to do something you can
ask them for help but they may not
always just follow orders in this case
you need rocket to get the doors open
but he's not thrilled about having to
crawl through ducts and mess with wires
there's also a puzzle that needs solving
and using quill's special visor you can
have a look around the room to complete
the circuit connections that power the
door you can also power up a vending
machine to help drax grab a drink and
you can accidentally power up a
defective console that blows up almost
in gamora's face causing her to yell at
you for your carelessness all of those
little moments are optional but they
each trigger more dialogue among the
guardians that continues to develop
their characters and adds more humor to
the goings-on later when you hit another
locked door that requires rocket's
expertise he straight up refuses to open
it which demonstrates why idos is
calling it the guardian request system
rocket is tired of wandering around the
station looking for people and unless
quill agrees that he's not going to lead
them through the entire rock rocket
won't open any more doors for the group
with the request system you can also try
to ask the other guardians for
assistance since they don't have the
expertise they instead will weigh in on
the situation leading to some fun jokes
like drax suggesting you negotiate with
the rodent rocket eventually agrees to
open the door but only after quill
agrees to end the search after just one
more room that one room of course is the
turning point of the level when you find
a nova corps helmet and are able to
listen into local communications here
you start to get a sense of what's going
on when you hear some weird religious
chatter between the nova troopers and
apparently they're searching for someone
this also presents one of the major
choice moments in the level where you
can decide to either speak up and ask
the nova corps folks what's going on or
remain silent on our first playthrough
in the chapter we stayed silent and
through the next door we found an
elevator with a glass wall through it
the guardians watched as some novacore
soldiers with weird purple halos of
energy around their heads executed some
of their comrades seems like some kind
of cultish mind control situation is
happening and since we didn't make our
presence known on the radio the
guardians were able to sneak into the
room and take the cultists by surprise
that kicked off combat for the first
time where we got a sense of how
teamwork permeates all levels of the
game quill on his own isn't a
particularly strong fighter he carries a
couple of guns and sports his signature
jet boots allowing you to run or fly
around the battlefield to hit different
targets or drop into cover but while
quill's guns do some damage and he can
fight hand to hand neither is always
super effective against all enemies
luckily quill's guns have elemental
add-ons that give you different benefits
in the demo we had access to an ice
element that allowed quill to freeze
enemies which made them easy targets for
the other guardians in combat the rest
of your team will take on enemies on
their own with each fighting in their
own way rocket sports an arsenal of
heavy weapons groot ties enemies up with
his roots and drax and gamora close the
distance to fight with melee weapons or
hand to hand but you can still use the
guardian request system here where you
can call on each member of the team to
use specific abilities on individual
targets so freezing a tough enemy with
quills guns allows you to then call on
drax to hit that enemy with a big attack
doing massive damage gamora's assassin
abilities are great for taking out
distant snipers while groot can tie up
multiple enemies with his vines and
briefly take them out of the battle
rocket has a powerful grenade that's
great for damaging several enemies at
once
so alone none of the guardians are
particularly strong or suited for every
situation but together they're extremely
formidable
as quill it's up to you to give orders
in the fight paying attention to what
threats are the priority and knowing
which guardians can best deal with them
the demo quickly started mixing tougher
enemies with the grunts as we fought our
way through them including a big guy who
sported an energy shield that made him
tough to shoot using groot or drax to
distract that enemy was key allowing
quill to flank him to avoid the shield
blasts from the freeze gun left the
enemy vulnerable so gamora could get in
and do some big damage and if you
attacked the enemy in the back you could
destroy the shield generator taking away
its defensive advantage if the guardians
are hurt or caught in a trap like the
electric mines the shield enemy would
sometimes send out it was up to quill to
help them or break them free leave the
guardians on their own too long and they
start to go down like squad mates in
games such as gears of war requiring you
to revive them if you're winning the
fight and playing effectively though the
game rewards you with a sort of combo
tracker that shows just how well you're
synergizing with the guardians and that
boosts your experience point gains
eventually you can initiate a momentary
boost called the huddle which also
charges on a timer the huddle pauses the
action and brings the guardians to quill
for a quick pep talk but you have to
make sure you're paying attention to
your squad in order to effectively pump
them up the different members of your
team will talk about how the fight is
going using keywords that hang on your
screen you then have two options for
your response and you need to pick the
pep talk response that's right for the
situation if the guardians are
demoralized you can reiterate that the
group is capable of taking on anything
when they work together if they're
fighting over who's kicking more ass you
can implore them not to get cocky and to
support each other so everyone can kick
even more ass the huddle is a great
emergency measure because it
automatically revives anyone on the team
who is downed even if you pick the wrong
answer but if you pick the right one the
guardians are energized by quills
coaching and everyone gets a momentary
damage boost when they get back into the
fight it's another way the game
emphasizes the team over the individual
and reiterates that you're a key part of
the group playing through the demo a
second time also showed how choices can
impact combat encounters if you choose
to talk to the novacore through the
helmet a group of cultists will come
looking for you and you lose the element
of surprise when they show up forcing
you into a fight in the next scene when
you're in the elevator the cultist
enemies know you're coming and they open
fire on the glass window so instead of
getting the drop on enemies drax
literally leaps out of the elevator and
starts wailing on people quill's jet
boots allow him to follow but the rest
of the team can't just jump down three
stories so the first part of the fight
is just quill and drax while you wait
for the other guardians to catch up and
in order to make it through you really
have to step up for your game as a
leader a few moments later the rest of
the team joins the battle and their
banter reflects how you did you might
hear rocket remark that the team owes
drax a beer for ripping through the
enemy novacore if you do well in the
fight so ultimately your choices might
lead to the same places it seems but not
necessarily in the same way
while your decisions with the guardians
and how you treat them might influence
how the story unfolds and their
relationships with you idos montreal
noted that they won't affect combat
rocket might complain about opening a
door because you haven't been listening
to him throughout a mission but that
doesn't mean he's going to refuse orders
while you're in combat ido said it
didn't want players to feel panelized by
their choices in combat so the team will
always fight to their fullest when it
counts but in between battles the
interpersonal dynamics come through and
the guardians pay attention to your
choices like whether you risked speaking
on the nova corps radio or stayed quiet
we also got a sense of how progression
will work in guardians of the galaxy
throughout the level you can find
supplies on the ground to collect
specifically two different kinds of
materials gathering those materials
allows you to upgrade quills gear at
work benches unlocking new abilities for
yourself like boosts for your boots or
upgrades for your guns and your scanner
that can give you information about
enemies fighting well also earns you
experience points you can spend on any
of the guardians to unlock new abilities
you can add to quill's arsenal of moves
like adding the ability to hover over
the battlefield to get better sight
lines on enemies or throw more options
to the rest of the guardians for when
you use the request system in a fight
each of the moves has different stats so
you can see how much each attack will
damage enemies how many people it can
target how long it will make your
cooldown timer last and how much it
contributes to filling up enemies
stagger meters which can stun them and
leave them open to more attacks knowing
what abilities are good in which
situations is essential to winning
fights and the better job you do
synergizing each team member's moves the
more experience you earn to buy new
abilities the demo ended soon after a
few more big fights with various enemies
requiring changes and tactics in order
to deal with each one the team finally
made their way back to their ship with
the guardians constantly bantering and
joking the whole way through through
combat character moments between fights
and the decision points throughout the
demo it was remarkable how much
guardians of the galaxy captures the
feeling of being a member of a team even
if the rest of the team is controlled by
ai it all suggests that guardians of the
galaxy is a superhero game that's not
going to feel like other superhero games
but it does a great job of capturing the
humor dysfunction and camaraderie that
makes the guardians of the galaxy such a
great group of characters
chew move over
what are you looking at
oh no you ain't chewing through any more
of my ship my ship
shoot [ __ ] off